i think what we've built in the
community where we're helping and we're
aspiring to
you know to create stronger and better
and more educated dog owners who are
making better choices for their pets i
think that's really inspired us to keep
going when as you said there have been
times where
you know it have been dark times of
course but we've seen recessions we've
seen wars we've seen pandemics and
dog owners are here to stay
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders my next guest is talking from
london and he is a co-founder of doggies
well it's about dogs meets danny genogly
the chief operating officer and
co-founder of doggies
danny was born and raised in london
before making aliyah when he was 18
serving as a lone soldier in the idf he
studied government and politics at the
idc where he adopted his dog and best
friend mufasa
this app is talking about the
relationship between pet owners and pets
not just for how to take care of them in
the day-to-day with their logistics but
how do we make more significant impact
on
on our understanding of what's happening
with them health-wise welcome danny
[Music]
you're dealing with a one of my favorite
worlds
animals pet care dog care and you know
something that
you know so many people you know today
have dogs you probably have better
statistics than i do and it's such an
important you know part of our lifestyle
of how do we how do we deal with this
how do we manage this and not trivial at
all we before we started recording we
touched on on a few of those of those
subjects and but tell me a little bit
about yourself danny how do you find
yourself
becoming a co-founder
in a startup that's all about dogs
excellent question um
i suppose kind of already began uh in uh
well originally i was kind of born and
raised in london i moved to israel when
i was 18 may dalian and
as a known soldier and in fear i then
studied at idc and had celia and
and it was there where i adopted mufasa
i'd show you a little bit you can say
hello to him it's uh he's had it all
before so you have to forgive if he's uh
sleeping he's a little bit unwell at the
moment recovering which is why he's got
his little hat on uh but yeah i don't
think my dog in uh whilst i was at
university um and it was there kind of
where i met my co-founder anan um in the
startup class we were both kind of i
studied government and politics he
studied economics that very quickly
realized that
economists and politicians we probably
wouldn't be um and then kind of we we
started cam you know came up with the
idea um and then kind of when i left
uni
i kind of was i suppose like many
students kind of a little bit lost
wasn't really sure
what you know what to do uh applied for
a few jobs tell that i was totally
unemployable so i had to start my own
company
but i think really the real truth of the
inspiration was was really was my job
and fafsa which i think was i joke that
you know 10 years ago now when i adopted
him that today it was the single best
decision i made ever was was adopting my
dog um and
yeah i think he just kind of became the
inspiration it very much became a
personal journey and a personal problem
and i suppose
i went from uni and you know juggling
lectures and part-time jobs and and
girlfriends and we might be like my
co-founder as well time you know his
wife and
studying and working and having big dogs
and small apartments um you know we we
started off more as tackling kind of on
the on the professional pet care side of
things so
not walking day care boarding and we
both kind of had bad experiences of you
know relying on the neighbor or the
granny who said you come in or a friend
who lets you down and it always kind of
just felt
at the end of the day it was always the
dog who who was suffering and so that's
why we started off originally morris we
wanted to create
an answer for professional pet cat um
you know find the best service for for
their best friend and and i think that's
this has you touched upon it we've seen
now our generation i think it's been
happening over the last 10 15 20 years
this what they're calling the
humanization of pets and it's the way
that you and i look at our pets in a
very different way to our parents or
grandparents generation whereas maybe 20
years ago you had a dog and you slept in
the garage and you gave them your
leftovers or you gave them this you know
the cheap shitty food that you got in in
the supermarket nowadays we're seeing
that really people's dogs are becoming
beloved members of of their family i
think now pet ownership especially
millennials becoming one of the biggest
uh groups of pet owners i believe it's
it's coming close to 40 percent uh of
the
millennials and especially our new
owners and the numbers will blow your
mind of new adoption that came over
covered and that's something we'll touch
upon surely kind of how covert has
affected this market um but i think
that's
really as you said there's there's such
a strong emotional connection and
attachment um which which kind of only
really pet parents you know on the side
and that's why i'll straight away at the
beginning are you adobo now because it
just always the language even i found
even in the past with investors you know
i wish on linkedin if there was a way to
filter investors by thought owners it
would make my life
not really a lot easier uh
and yeah that that's clearly really my
dog was how i i got started and then
he's just been a roller coaster rider
ever since yeah i love it take take me
to covet and
and what's happened with clover i
remember all the headlines about how you
know it's impossible to fight to adopt
dogs because they're
everybody was looking to bring in dogs
but what was covert like for pet owners
and for you know the pet industry as a
whole
so
i think what what's really interesting
is the you know if you look at the
statistics and numbers of the pet space
in general and yeah pet yeah average
pet ownership is growing is growing the
market is growing at a ridiculous rate
and the average spend of of of pet
owners is increasing year on year and
you know we saw in 2008 when you know
with the recession um we saw you know a
study showing that people would rather
take cuts on you know getting less
takeaways but to keep their dalton on
premium dog food and you know that was
really the beginning where they said
maybe you know pets is this kind of
recession proof um then of course you
know the pandemic game and all these
questions of you know is this industry
also pandemic proof um i think
ironically this
the pandemic was was great for the
industry in the fact that the amount of
new pet owners and that you know that
came as a result of the pandemic i
believe in the uk it's around 3.2
million new homes took on pets in the
u.s you know some steam saying 30
percent of dog owners took on another
dog dog shelters as you said were kind
of emptied um
and i think it also made a lot of the
big brands realize
the importance of moving online and and
i think traditionally this industry has
been kind of very much the brick and
mortar you know you went to your local
pet shop and that was the guy you bought
your food from and and that was kind of
really it and whereas now we've seen
obviously with lockdowns and closures of
how
everything's moving online and i think
that's why
technology is kind of this has been a
huge catalyst but not just more dog
owners but i think the need for
technology to keep up with a lot of new
dog owners who don't have a clue what
they're doing even all the dog runners
who might necessarily know know what
they're doing that you know what we all
i think it's a general problem is a lack
of understanding in education within dog
owners and from a personal point of view
obviously our business was we were you
know a top walking business and we were
flying we were doing hundreds of
bookings a day we were took over the
whole of the israeli market we moved to
london
everything was going amazing um and then
the whole premise of our business was
you're at the office your dog's at home
let us take care of your dog and
obviously that came crashing down uh
with you know lockdowns and people
working from home and so
i would definitely say alan and i were
guilty here the first few months of
saying ah
i'm sure like everyone else this will be
over in a couple of weeks i'll be fine
you know and you see you're never kind
of planting you know 10 20 40 60 down 80
percent and you start thinking wow
like how long is this you know
going to carry on for and and i think
that was a really interesting kind of
time for
following i think personally also is
entrepreneurs i think sometimes when
things are going amazingly well
and yeah you know and alan always gives
us you know when you're running at 200
miles an hour sometimes it's kind of
hard to look left and right because
you're just you're putting out fireworks
you're working on growth you know so
much is going on and then all of a
sudden you're kind of hit by this
you know
quiet time where you know nothing's
happening you know for
everyone's at home lockdowns you know
what is that to do and you know we were
faced with some really tough choices you
know we had to go to our board and you
know we cut costs where we could and we
tried to preserve as much as we could
and you know of course we had a few
people who are uh you know with a lot of
cases of people who are actually had
covered that we walked their dog's forum
and you know there were small things
that we managed to keep our base though
our numbers dropped by
around 80 percent and so it was a huge
huge and we were kind of faced with
that reality of either we
we closed down and we go home then we
call it a day
or we go back to the drawing board and i
think and i you know by naturally we're
stopping bastards um and you know alan
as well has got background you know he's
originally a maid aliyah from from from
kazakhstan as a young boy in in
he then uh served in the in the navy
seals and the shrinkage lost the slaver
for six years so
you know
where neither of us are uh i would say
natural quitters and since you know this
often there the power is that how much
is stubbornness and stupidity and
bravery how often are they a good thing
all about it um and we kind of was faced
with the choice of you know either we
close down or we go back to the drawing
board and always along the way out of
the diary it had a vision of a much more
holistic platform to to give an offering
to not just you know the 15 to 20
percent of dog runners who used to
walkers but to build something that
would be
for all dog owners um and that's when we
kind of spoke with our community with
our dog owners with partners with our
walkers and
and that's kind of how we came up with
the whole idea of the dobby's 2.0 which
was a lot more focused on you know the
health and wellness and of
of thoughts and helping educate dog
owners to make better decisions about
their uh about their dog's health um
whereas in the past we were a lot more
of an operational company you know we
needed dog walkers and now we've kind of
shifted in focus to the technology side
of things um and alan and i kind of made
a decision that
we wanted to make sure that we came out
of covert in an even stronger position
then we came in to cover it and we came
in to cover that flying like you know
january february our q1 expert yeah
forecast media already smashed our q1
forecast the full coverage even hit and
but then do you know march the 10th or
march 16th whatever it was
well
the hit the fan as they say and so
it was the top few months uh definitely
uh some some
you know interesting interesting times
but i think ironically
covert was the best thing that happened
for our business and sure obviously
it wasn't great but i think you know we
were lucky also to have investors who
believes in us and we have partners and
and brands that we working with who who
love the idea of the new product
it was built kind of
as a direct result of speaking to our
customers you know what do you want and
we did focus groups and we had a lot
more time on our hand um and it's
it's
it says it was really a blessing in in
disguise
and i think now as we kind of come i
don't even know from owls covered i
don't know now i feel like there's this
other new like silent wave that's coming
up everyone yeah no one's talking about
it
and then we have the ukraine crisis so i
was like okay vladimir putin has he has
he beaten covered and then now and like
is it back is it not kind of no one's
announced the heat wave so no one's
talking about it but uh it's you know i
think this world in general is is
is is waiting for disruption and i think
us pet owners are motivated by a huge
emotional connection in front
with our dog owners um and that's
really how we decided to kind of come up
with it with this new platform was
as a direct result of cover but also as
part of a thinking of learning our
market for you know being in the
industry for quite a few years it really
enabled us to get a unique insight to
how this market works and who are the
players there
and although it kind of feels like we
started a new
start-up you know it's built on you know
some years
before i started this you know this is
uh
i love
it what is what so what is what is dog
is 2.0 how do you how are you bringing
sort of lifestyle education
and you know
pet care beyond just the the services
portion of what doggies was what are
sort of the big the big aha moments
you've had sure so really i said we
wanted to put a much larger focus on on
health and wellness and
in technology and i think kind of some
of the other plans we were seeing in
the human world but i think covered was
great for bridging the gaps and
telemedicine and and everything moving
online and zoom calls with you know
you're you're seeing a doctor online and
we wanted to make uh
something that would make it easier for
dubliners to access their information
and so how it works kind of the new
platform is dog owners you register you
fill in a quiz so we can kind of get to
know your dot we then kind of set you
fun challenges and to improve the health
and wellness or the activity of your dog
so you can kind of you know track your
walk so we kind of give you achievements
and for every achievement that you earn
you earn doggy's coins
which you can then use as discounts on
our services or on our partners products
something that we took as well from the
world we're seeing this huge trend of
gamification and we've seen that across
a a lot of different uh you know sectors
and especially communal whether it be
strava of people competing how far they
run or uh or different types of
businesses or you know playlist and
trying to push people to be more active
and healthy uh we wanted to do the same
with with dog owners and reward them
with
discounts on premium products and
services
that
on activities that they're already doing
you know you already walked your dog why
not show you three doggies and then and
as you go and kind of give you that cash
back and the idea was to motivate you
and to reward you for being
a better dog owner or someone in terms
of more accurate because i think what
really ultimately underlines everything
is that
the foundation is
healthy dogs are happy dogs and actors
right but you know are healthier dogs
and so that's kind of how we started and
then the main kind of features that we
developed was the big one was is dr poop
so it's the first ever
machine like that
i know it's a great one you can take a
picture of your dog's poop and instantly
be able to find out if it's healthy um
or not and this again
that's huge spread to our vets speaking
with our vet partners and you know we're
going to be adding online vet services
as well but when we were kind of
speaking with our vets you know and i
was having a meeting with him and you
know he just kept on getting these
whatsapp pictures uh he's like he's just
ready to release how many pictures of
i get every week i'm like what do
you mean like who is sending you you
know
pictures of their dog's food and it
turns out it's not just neurotic jewish
mothers but all pet owners you know have
this worry is everything okay if
something doesn't look right and we then
kind of you know built a whole study of
you know spoke with 10 different vets
took 100 samples of poo to try and see
if there was any uh you know validation
occurs between the vets uh results uh we
then have now
building this machine learning
technology that
in the last three weeks since we
launched we've now analyzed the nearly
three and a half thousand
dog food pictures which we've kind of
given them three grades so around 67
percent of them are
everything looks great everything looks
fine around
uh average when we say you know kind of
we need a couple more samples or
something you know
something that you know we just need a
few more samples to for a better
judgment and
have come out with
something looks wrong you need to speak
to the vet and and i think
what's been so interesting like is this
from a personal point of view we touched
upon input about uh with my doctors
unfortunately and i just feel recently
diagnosed with with cancer
ironically the reason why i went to the
vet was
because i noticed that he was just being
a bit constipated and he was just
struggling to do it and his poo was
looking fine but he was just really
strumming and it was when i went to the
vet and you know then they started
checking and then that's when they found
i know he had this this tumor on his
anal sac and that was what was blocking
him and and it was all to do with you
know the fact that he wasn't appearing
normally um and i think that kind of
also really showed me and even now you
know over the last 3 000 pictures over
300 people you know have had problems
now again not all of them are
drastic serious problems and but it's
about creating that awareness and making
tools a lot easier for dog owners to to
understand their their dog's health and
and make it easier and accessible to to
get quick
answers when they need them
i love it so so danny first of all um
very very cool very cool journey a very
inspiring journey you know in the
trenches for eight years making him
making an impact but really you know
really pushing pushing the limits on on
on entrepreneurship and and ups and
downs and build and
navigating through and not just covet
but you know different consumer
behaviors shifting and and figuring out
how to enter new markets and new
segments it's a very very cool story no
you know if you had to distill it down
for you what you know why you're doing
what you're doing sort of why are you
why are you doing what you're doing what
way is that really so
well that's i think it's a combination i
think first of all obviously you know
there's the personal benefits of
you know creating a product which i
think
you know i i've
as a founder i've met incredible
founders who saw made brilliant products
to solve amazing problems for other
people and it is like it's amazing and i
take my hat off and i just found also
kind of i wanted something from a
personal problem to kind of see how we
could help um and i think as we've kind
of gone along and we've built this
community i think
there's just an intrinsic bond
between
dog owners there's an intrinsic trust
and there's a community out there um
just to give you an example of of
the amount of recommendations i've heard
even from myself or given to other
people that you've met from a stranger
in a dog park who tells you oh i see
your dog's limping have you tried these
supplements i tried them on my dog they
were amazing now i don't even know this
guy from adam but i trust him more than
i you know my vet or
you know an online google search because
there is an intrinsic bonds between us
all and it's very hard to explain to
people who
who don't have pets and i've been told
by people who have children that there's
a similar bond when you're at the
playground and your kid's crying and you
look at each other and you kind of give
that knowledge you know but it's
i think i would kind of hey i'm
amazingly lucky to have an incredible
business father who's become one of my
closest friends and i think as you
mentioned
it's a roller coaster ride with many ups
and downs and having someone who
not just balances you out on the work
side of things where you know things
that he's better at things like i'm
better at learning to work but having
actually you know his wife george zama
is you know his second wife the amount
we speak with each other and you know so
having someone like that is really makes
things easier and i think what we've
built in the community where we're
helping and we're aspiring to
you know to create stronger and better
and more educated dog owners who are
making better choices for their pets i
think that's really
inspired us to keep going when as you
said there have been times where
you know it's it have been dark times of
course but we've seen recessions we've
seen wars we've seen pandemics and
dog owners are here to stay and i think
now it's it's all about you know the
technology that's right right for for
disrupting this market on a on a serious
level um and i'm really excited now this
new
product and this year's it has given us
a new you know blood of energy and uh a
new determination where as you said
sometimes in startups if you're not
moving forward you
you and you're you're saying still
you're finished that's just how it
exactly is
forward you're moving backwards and if
you're moving backwards in this game
unfortunately it never ends well um and
so we've been lucky you know as our
business model has changed and i think
we've always enjoyed that challenge and
i think part of
these tough times as an entrepreneur is
looking where things are working well
it's very easy when things are very well
but it's taking those tough decisions
when things aren't going well and not
being so arrogant to be like oh the
first time i got it right
and be able to morph and understand your
market and move with your market i think
really defines
when what makes entrepreneurs successful
is that try and fail and if you're going
to fail fail fast and you know and learn
quickly um and so that's
i think it's it's it's been it's been a
challenge sometimes i look you know like
you get jealous of your friends who
leave the office at 5 p.m and they don't
give a what happens whereas you
know but as
with time um
i think i'm i'm super grateful that i've
had this before we've had incredible
investors who've really believed in us
um as i said my i couldn't have done
that my business far and on is
you know incredible and we've got an
amazing team now that have been
you know inspire us every day and pretty
much everyone's a dog owner it's not a
prerequisite to our company but it's
just
it's kind of always just worked out that
way uh i love it that's kind of really
you know what we've
what what's inspires our sister you know
help our
our four-legged friends in in every way
we can er amazing journey danny thank
you for that and thank you for these 20
minutes uh i look forward to continue
continuing to follow a dog's journey
and your own journey so thank you very
much for the time and the inspiration
best of luck and
a quick recovery for your dog
thank you again for being here my
pleasure thank you so much for having me
[Music]